I mean that doesn't look so much like
tennis it looks like they're sort of
swinging like a lightsaber or something
that's not really oh my god oh here we
go through the leg shot tweener
very good that was very good difficult
shot to pull off the between Oh
especially on their artificial grass the
first thing you want to make sure is
that when you're sort of actually once
you've hit the ball that you don't sort
of follow through and and and hit your
own balls yeah he got a very good
contact on that oh no I guess I had a
feeling something like how it's gonna
happen there
those that yeah that's that's
embarrassing there's a good video that
happened to a similar thing happened to
Roger Federer a few years ago so it can
happen so that it can happen to the best
of us if you're not careful like that
taking the return nice and early
there's doubles here okay that is that
is a proper that's a proper helicopter
out of the court there and I think well
deserved it was a horrible volley on top
of the net another lefty oh wow I've
seen people do that similar thing where
they missed the serve intentionally but
then he's but then is hit it from behind
his back I mean that's a any sort of he
didn't even react like that was you know
like he reacted like that was sort of
run-of-the-mill stuff as well
I mean that doesn't look so much like
tennis it looks like they're sort of
swinging like a lightsaber or something
that's not really oh my god oh no that
didn't sound good at all I hope she's
okay yeah not the ending I was expecting
they're together I like this it looks
like they're got a forfeit coming up for
someone but we used to play that sort of
games you know with a bunch of friends
for like forfeits and that's always been
the sort of the tennis for a butts up
yeah I'd probably try and avoid Nick
kurios he's got an unbelievably live arm
east you conserved like a hundred forty
miles an hour and I know he plays those
sorts of games all the time so and I
don't I don't think he'd be holding back
on anyone whereas some of the guys you
know when he did that they kind of you
know they're not they're not trying to
destroy him
whereas I think Nick probably would I
loved I loved playing short tennis when
I was younger
nice volleys good footwork it's pretty
rare you see young kids playing up at
the net now that's a nice volley to
finish with love a bit short tennis and
yeah nice to see the the youngster up at
the up of the net they're getting the
better of whoever she was playing with
me and my brother we used to play for
the dumb Blaine Sports Club third team
like men's doubles teams so we didn't
really know how to keep score at that
age so we were kind of always you know
men making mistakes with that stuff
but yeah when we were like seven eight
years old we were playing with yes some
some oldies and getting a pair of them
not a lefty a lot lefties in here oh
nice I have seen that before but that
was well executed I mean you made that
look pretty easy but that's yeah that's
tough there is a guy who plays an old
like the vet
events called monster Bahrami if you not
watched any videos of him
I mean he's brilliant so entertaining
like really really good you worth
watching some of his videos okay in
third place I'm gonna take the guy who
hit the shot it was kind of where he
missed a serve hit behind his back and
then sort of walk forward like he'd done
that a hundred times which I don't
believe he has so I'll take him and
number three more for the reaction than
anything else in second place I'm gonna
take the two girls that were sort of
playing era tennis and then where she
felt was sounded like she fell flat on
the back of her head and I've heard
she's okay so that's why I'm taking it
but yeah it was pretty pretty pretty
shocking video that one in first place
I'm gonna take the video of the little
girl playing short tennis because she
actually looks like she was trying to
play tennis rather and just taking trick
shots and I hope she grows up to be a
good tennis player